in this course you will learn all about
JavaScript functions as one of the
foundational pillars of programming
understanding functions is crucial for
every aspiring developer this course
will provide you a comprehensive
overview of functions in JavaScript
breaking down complex Concepts into
digestible modules from the essentials
of what functions are and why they're
indispensable to diving deep into
terminologies Scopes closures and
advanced patterns like higher order
functions and recursion this video will
help you become an expert at functions
Tapas has over 18 years of coding
experience and has a passion for
teaching and creating open source
communities he's the teacher of this
course so let's get started Hello
friends how are you doing what is this
crash course about the crash course is
about JavaScript functions so we'll be
going through a bunch of details about
JavaScript functions in and out and try
to understand with lots of code like how
it works fundamentally one thing I keep
saying folks is that the concept is much
much bigger than the syntaxes while
we'll be writing code but we want to
deep down in the concept first and then
complete that with the syntaxes I hope
you enjoy this entire course and if you
so please like and share this video if
you have any doubts comment below I am
going to respond to you with all the
doubts clarifications be assured about
that okay so a few things before you get
started how to take this course this is
a longer video because of course it's a
crash course we I have to fit in a lot
of stuff within one video but if you
follow certain patterns you will be
enjoying the entire journey of going
through each and every topic that we are
discussing in this video okay so first
thing take breaks don't try to consume
all the content at once take adequate
breaks and then try to feel like what
you have learned are just few seconds
back
second thing after every logical chapter
within this course try to understand
whether you have completely got the
concept or not if not go back and try to
relearn no problem anytime go and try to
relearn I will be teaching lot of
exercises so you have to do this
exercise with me but don't type them as
I am teaching okay first try to
understand what I am teaching try to
completely get it in into yourself and
after that pause the video try to do
this you know those those code part by
yourself all the code examples are
already there on GitHub and the link to
that is there in the comment section but
in the description section of this video
you can anytime pull it up and try to
see like you know what is the code look
like so no worries about that but don't
type the code as I am teaching because
then you won't be focusing on what I am
teaching rather focus on learning and
then try the code out so go repeat come
back learn and everything and in case
there is nothing clear feel free to
comment I am going to respond to you
look without any further delay let us
get started
[Music]
foreign
let's quickly talk about the concepts
we'll be covering in this crash course
so first thing we'll be talking about
JavaScript functions fundamentals what
is function what is it used about a very
very basic level right I'm considering a
beginner when they watch this crash
course they will be able to understand
what functions are and why they are used
then we'll be clarifying few
terminologies there are few
terminologies which are a bit confusing
when you learn functions for example
functions versus methods parameters
versus arguments and there are many more
such terminologies that we want to
clarify next we want to talk about
function declarations we'll be talking
about function executions then we'll get
into call stack we'll talk about Arrow
function nested function function scope
we'll talk about closure we'll talk
about callback functions higher order
functions pure functions we'll talk
about iifv we'll talk about recursion so
there are lots lots lots to learn there
are lots to talk about that's that's why
I told you like when we go to each of
this chapter in this course try to
understand one chapter before you go to
the next one and please practice the
chapter before you go to the next one
alright so take your time and let's get
started with the learning the first one
about JavaScript functions and its
fundamentals so what is Javascript
function before I get there let me tell
you a story is the story of two frames
one of the frame actually trying to cook
a dish but she doesn't know the recipe
of how to cook it so she called her
friend who is sitting abroad over phone
try to ask for the recipe for the friend
at the other end she received the call
and told the recipe line by line saying
that hey if you want to cook this dish
you have to follow this recipe like you
have to put this first then you have to
put this one then you have to cook it
for so long and then finally your dish
is ready great the friend cook the dish
following the recipe that she got but
after a week when she tried to cook it
again
she felt like okay let me ring up my
friend again and try to ask the recipe
and the same thing happened the friend
gave the recipe over phone she followed
the instruction cook the favorite dish
next month the story remains same she
calls up the friend again again got the
recipe cook the dish for few months it
went on like that but after that even
though they are very best friend the
friend who is sitting abroad really got
frustrated of it and just told hey I
have been telling you this recipe for
like four or five months now why don't
you write it down somewhere so that you
don't have to ask me again and again and
I don't have to perform this task of
telling you again and again rather
wherever you are writing it you probably
can fetch it from there then what the
friend did she wrote the every
instruction in a diary and next time
onward she never rang up the friend
abroad rather followed it from the diary
JavaScript functions a little bit like
that
so it saves you from repeating the same
task again and again rather you put the
task somewhere and then reuse that every
time you have to perform the same
similarly to that friend's story who
wanted to create cook the dish but
finally actually instead of giving the
task of her friend to tell it again and
again repeatedly she fetched it from the
diary the friend never had to perform
the task again
okay so with this analogy in mind like
reducing the task performing the task
again and again rather we will create
something so that we can actually reuse
it whenever required in our programming
that's the very very fundamental aspect
of functions now you'll be getting into
a graphics through which the similar
kind of story we'll be putting into the
code in a visual way and try to
understand what exactly function does
programming the yellow box you see in
the screen consider that is a program
and in that you have bunch of lines of
code
now just look at it a little bit closely
there is a color coding there are a
bunch of black lines then there is a
green line again bunch of black lines
there is a red orange blue
again bunch of black lines and then
there is a white line right so what do
you try to mean here those black lines
are the kind of code the same code has
been repeated multiple times so three
black lines then some other code then
again same three black lines have been
repeated then some other code then again
three black lines got repeated like that
right so there is a repetition exist now
we want to bring in the concept of
JavaScript JavaScript functions here so
that we can reduce this repetition so
what we do basically in this case you
know going forward
is we first Mark what are those lines
that is that are getting repeated so you
see here we have marked those lines that
are getting repeated and the next thing
that we do is like how can we make this
code better so that we don't repeat the
same task write the same lines rather
than that we kind of take those lines
somewhere give it a name in this case
the name is like if you win fun and then
what you do is like the same code that
we got change it in such a way that
instead of those line we are going to
use the same entity the fun we had
created before so do you see this one
the number of lines of code has reduced
drastically so what we did instead of
repeating the same task in your code the
first one
we have now put the code in something
which we call as function given it a
name called if you win fun and then use
that if you and fun in our code instead
of repeating those lines every time so
we are not only reducing the number of
lines of code in you know in our total
source code but what we are also doing
is basically we are reusing something
again and again now think about a case
like why why do we need it the best case
probably is let's say there is a problem
in these three lines there is a bug in
these three lines so in the previous
case if there is a bug and you have to
fix that bug or you have to fix that
issue you have to fix this issue at
least three times so you have to fix it
in the first branch of line then again
the second bunch of lines then again in
the third bunch of line but as we have
put this thing into a function in a
single place and then reusing the same
with its name in the multiple different
places if you have to fix the bug now
you have to fix it in one place
just inside that function's body just
inside that function and then rest of it
will work so functions are a bunch of
blocks that you keep together to perform
something which otherwise will be very
very repeated in your code function
should ideally have a name but it can be
without a name also in most of the cases
you will have function with a name so
that you can call the function with that
name so you me every human being has a
name and the purpose of the name is like
we will be called by that name and when
someone will call us by that name we'll
respond and say hey I am here I am I am
the person similarly for the function
when we call the function by the name
function we'll say like hey I am here
and inside this I have this bunch of
code go ahead and execute this code okay
so that's the beauty of JavaScript
function I hope you understood it I know
these graphics and please keep it in
your brain because you know the rest of
the crash course we are going to use
this terminology again and again you
know for better understanding in
programming at times terminologies are
much more harder than the programming
itself
and when a developer gets stuck on those
terminologies they feel so discouraged
of learning that particular programming
language it happens so that's where
where you are learning any programming
language or an aspect of a programming
language you have to make sure that we
understand certain terminologies very
well when you are learning JavaScript
functions there are few terminologies
that you also need to know and you have
to differentiate between them very well
so some of the terminologies are
functions and methods what are the
differences we are going to talk about
that then declaration and definitions
what is the difference is there a
difference between them arguments and
parameters we'll be talking about that
as well and then call back and hire
other functions
they will get confused often with these
two so we'll be talking that also deep
down when you go in the course itself so
these terminologies keep in your mind
like when we are talking about it make
sure that in new head this terminologies
and the differences or the similarities
is completely chalked out completely
clear if not go back and try to see like
where I have explained this one if you
still have further questions ask them in
your comment section I'll get back to
you
[Music]
let us now start creating functions and
try to learn like how do we create
functions okay as a thing before that so
you can use any editor like you can use
Visual Studio code or any other editor
of your choice while coding what I am
using right now I am using browsers
depth tools and the console tab so that
I can write the program here and execute
them then and there so if you want any
other mechanism like you will be writing
on Visual Studio code and use the live
server to run your program most welcome
or you can actually practice them on the
browser's dev tool just go press f2l
open the dev tools go to console Tab and
start writing your program and execute
it because you're just practicing at
this point of time so first first thing
first what we'll be doing now is we'll
be creating functions so we told that
function is something which is going to
help you to keep a bunch of instruction
and code in a place so that you can
reuse it again and again when you need
it now to declare or to define a
function so our first terminology Bank
declaration versus definition so these
two things are exactly same when it
comes to function function declaration
function definitions defining a function
is kind of same so if somebody is saying
I'm declaring a function or another
person saying I'm defining a function
they are actually talking about the same
thing which is nothing but creating a
function with bunch of logic so what we
are going to do now we are first going
to create a function so to do that I
have to use a keyword called function
this is the keyword and then I have to
give the function a name I told just now
the function may or may not have a name
but most of the time the function will
have a name so that we can call the
function by its name just like the human
being has name there are situations
where the function may not have a name
and we'll talk about the situations in
the in in some time in this course okay
so let's first give a name let's give a
name called print me and then
you know curly braces and then close
that Curly braces so this is what you
have declared or you have defined a
function okay so right now the function
has a keyword a name a bunch of
parenthesis and then curly braces open a
curly braces n inside this curly braces
you are going to write every logic that
you want this function to have so that
you can reuse this logic anywhere you
want so for example
this particular function may just log
certain thing into this console so you
do console.log
console.log console is like an you know
something that you already have uh with
JavaScript on this particular debugger
so that you can use it for your coding
purpose for your debugging purpose and
on Console you have varieties of methods
one of the method is log through which
you can log something in the console so
that you know you can actually read them
or it's more for the debugging purpose
that you can use okay so let us do
something like printing something like
this okay so I have created a function
with a function keyword and the name
called print me and the instruction the
function has is a log that I want to
print in the console and that logs is
printing that's it so this is my
function definition or function
declaration now as I have declared this
function with the name the next thing
that I can do beautifully is by calling
this function so to call this function
just type the name of the function you
know print me over here there is
autocomplete already and then to call it
you have to give this parenthesis
otherwise you are just printing this
particular function's name and if you
just do this the function is going to
print its complete body itself so if you
just do print me the name itself it is
going to give you a string version of
the entire functions definition or
Declaration that you have done just now
but to execute to call it specifically
you have to give this parenthesis you
must give this parenthesis and then you
press enter it will give its output it's
just log printing because that's exactly
what we asked this particular function
to do so our function has worked that's
great now
as the function has worked
um I want to just do something more with
this okay so this is where what I am
going to introduce something called
parameter okay so let's write the same
function function and we will say the
name is print this
and we will pass something over here
which we call as parameter I'll get into
it in a minute and then I'll close this
functions body and inside this what I'm
going to do I am going to write like
console DOT log param
so what does it what what does it mean
what what I have done here okay so I
have first
similarly created a function with the
function keyword and the function name
here I have not done anything between
these two parentheses but in this case I
have done something in the parenthesis
so whatever you put inside this
parenthesis of a function it's called
parameters okay whatever you put inside
this parenthesis as called parameters
you can put as many parameters that you
wish to as long as you need in your
programming logic so if I am passing
param is going to just you know I can
use this param anywhere inside this
function so that I can do something with
it so for example I can just now do
print this and pass
this is going to print the thing that I
have just given over here so it means I
can pass a value to a function and that
value actually get mapped to the
parameter and that's something that I
can use you know inside the function to
do anything that we want so again there
is a thing that I want to call out over
here there is a terminal logic thing a
parameter versus argument anything in
the function definition you pass inside
this parenthesis is a parameter but when
you call this function invoke this
function the actual value that you are
passing to this function is called
argument okay so that's the difference
sometime what happened that we call this
also as parameter that I am passing the
parameter we call this as an argument
that I am passing the argument that's
not the case so parameter is something
that you pass to a function while
declaring or defining the function which
is like this but when you call invoke
this function the actual value you pass
to it it's called the arguments so I
hope this is clear to you the parameter
versus argument okay great so we have
defined the function and we have now
know what is parameter we have now what
exactly is
you know uh argument and and things like
that okay so the next thing we have
defined the function but there is one
more way we can actually declare or
Define the function that's called using
the function Expressions okay so what is
expression let's learn but before that
let me just clear it off all this thing
that I have done because I don't need it
so if I say const
count equals to 100. this is an
expression what this expression has it
has a variable name called count it has
like you know how we have defined this
variable we are saying this variable is
a constant and then is a value of this
particular variable okay so const count
equals to 100 is an expression exactly
similarly we can actually Define a
function so let's take the print me
function itself so print the print me
function the print me is nothing but the
function name which we can actually put
as a variable over here and then what we
can do here instead of that 100 value we
can give function itself is a value and
then we give the functions body and
inside this function body we can give
whatever we need sorry it's got executed
my bad I'll just put it over here
um you can give console Dot
log
say print
right so this is what I have done so I
have const print me equals to function
and then this this thing so previously
what I have done previously I have done
this function
print me
okay and then I have done here
console.log say
printing
so now I have just defined the function
but I have defined the function in the
function expression way so it means that
the name that I have used for function
before now it's a variable basically and
then the variable what I have assigned
is nothing but a function I have
assigned that a function so it means
print me is nothing but a function now
when if I did const print me equals to
100 print p is nothing but a number
which value is hundred now I have done
cons print me equals to function that
means print B is a function and then I
should be able to execute this function
so first I'll Define this okay print me
has already declared because I have used
this let's use some other name for now
say print me again okay so this is the
name and then I do print me again
and I have to execute means I have to do
this parenthesis and I got the print so
this is another way I can actually
Define and declare a function right now
in the same thing in the print me again
let's say print me again and let's say
with param what I can do now I can
actually put any parameter here right
pair or I'll this time I'll put two
parameters A and B and here after coming
I'll be actually doing a and b
I have done now declared it now let's
say print
me again with param if I do 10 and 20 as
an argument is going to print 10 10 10
10 and 20. so I hope this is clear and
now you know like how we can actually
Define a function or declare a function
there are two ways we have done okay so
one is with expression another is
without expression let's learn
how to return from a function so return
is something you will be using very
often when you work with functions uh so
far what we have done we have created a
function but inside that we have just
done a console.log statement which is
not enough usually what happens is like
when you create a function let's say
function X and you have something over
here right and then you will have say
another function y
okay and you have something over here
and then each of these functions are
supposed to do their own task right and
in the entire program your entire
application is not like that you will
have only one function you will have
multiple functions and what we'll be
doing is like if function X whatever is
supposed to do what you can use is
basically you can use it like the output
value of function X and take this into a
variable like say late uh P equals to
this and basically can use this P
somewhere inside another function or
anywhere else that in that matter so
basically whatever the value of
that X function that returns you can
utilize that value anywhere else maybe
in another function or anywhere in your
programming right so that is that is
that is very much a feasible thing in
and the thing that you will be
definitely doing now this thing to
happen if you see this expression let me
remove everything over here and just to
put this for your consumption this this
particular expression what we are doing
we are having a variable called p and
the piece value is what is not the
function but the value we get from
executing a function because we told
a function name along with the
parenthesis means executing calling
invoking a function a function name
without a parenthesis means it adjusts
the string representation of the
function definition itself this is a
this is a difference that you have to
keep in mind so in this case we have
parenthesis means the function will
execute function will be called or
function will be invoked and within that
if the function is returning any value
that value will be assigned to this
variable what if the function doesn't
return any value here what if it just
has a console.log like we have seen the
function so far in that case simply the
function execution will return something
very special which is called undefined
okay it means that something that is not
defined yet is something called
undefined okay so now let us create a
function that returns something so for
that
we'll create a function say sum and
we'll do a summation addition of two
things so we will take a and b as two
parameters terminology matters and what
we'll do is like we'll do return of a
plus b simple so it means that this is a
function whose name is sum takes two
parameters A and B it sum up those two
parameter with this arithmetic operation
and the result it returns you know back
so let's execute sum
it takes two arguments now let's put two
and three so it means we are expecting a
5 is returning a 5. in the same method
we can actually write little bit
differently how so let's write the same
method function sum
we will do again a comma B and in this
case we just did
return of a plus b instead of that
sometime you might want to do this also
like late
return a variable a plus b and then
return that particular variable itself
that is also same thing same as you know
we have done whatever we have done
before like returning a plus b directly
right so if it is just a simple
calculation returning it directly itself
will be a shorter amount of code that
people does so please follow that this
is about returning returning from a
function it means everything that you do
inside a function all the tasks all the
logic all the operations and at the end
of it if you want the function to return
a value so that that value can be
utilized elsewhere you have to use the
return statement followed by what you
want to return I hope this is clear
[Music]
what is default parameter when you
define a function we know how to define
a function so let's define a function
function will take the same okay a
little bit different function let's say
calc is a function and it takes a two
parameters A and B and what we do
we will return some value and the value
that we want to return is something like
2 into a plus b okay this is the value
we are planning to return so what does
this function do a simple function a
function whose name is calc takes two
parameters A and B what it returns is
for sum of these two parameters value
then multiply it with 2 and then return
something back a value back so let's
execute this let's call this function
with 2 comma 3 all right so what it
gives you it gives you 10 yeah of course
because 2 plus 3 is 5 5 into 2 is 10.
similarly you can go do three into three
what is going to give you 12 3 plus 3 is
6 into 2 is 12. now let's say someone in
the team forgot to pass this second
argument what you get you get not a
number why do you get an order number
because when you don't pass an argument
for a parameter for the function
the parameter value will be undefined we
told about that so it means that in this
case you are not passing the second
argument so value basically so then B
will be undefined now A Plus undefined
and a will be 3 B is undefined 3 plus
undefined is not a number of course it
returns not a number now on a situation
like this instead of getting not a
number you might want to safeguard it
with some kind of default value right
some kind of default value of this
parameters so that at least this one
fail like this rather you can Safeguard
them with some values of you know
something that you are liking okay so
what we are going to do the same
function I'm going to bring in again
and now I can actually default it to
zero okay it's a default value or
default value for this parameter that I
am putting so it means if someone is not
passing a value for this parameter using
the argument
s the value 0 will be used instead okay
so let's do this now I am going to do
calc 3 again if you see this now instead
of n a n not a number it is actually
retaining a value which is 6 which is
let's do the computation a is 3 B is 0 3
plus 0 is 3 3 into 2 is 6 okay so you
can
do a default parameter value for your
function if it is required to and in
that case you can Safeguard it from an
unnatural value return value from the
function like not a number and you can
actually override the undefined value
instead of having undefined you can now
set certain value with the default
parameter
[Music]
rest parameters what is rest parameter
so the rest parameter is something that
allows a function to accept
any number of arguments as an array any
number of arguments okay now theory is
one side let's do it with example let's
create a function let's say give a
function name
will give a name call say collect things
okay
and we will have two
parameters of it first is X and then is
y
now we are talking about rest parameters
a different kind of special parameters
right we know about default parameters
now now we are learning about the rest
parameters and I just now say the rest
parameter allows a function to accept
any number an infinite number of
arguments as an array now to make sure
the rest parameter accept an infinite
number of arguments what we have to do
you have to give a special syntax to it
the syntax is with three dots so when we
give three dots what happen is like this
this particular parameter becomes rest
parameter now here two things I want to
call out a function definition can have
only one rest parameter so it means that
you cannot do X comma rest parameter y
comma rest parameter Z you cannot do
that so it can have only one rest
parameter and the rest parameter must be
the last parameter that you define for
the function this two
rules please keep in mind I'll repeat
again a function definition can only
have one rest parameter as we have over
here with y
the rest parameter must be the last
parameter like how we have here so you
cannot have like you know making this X
as a rest parameter and then y as a
normal parameter you cannot have that
rather you have to have like this of
course the name suggests it means rest
means rest of it rest of it means
whatever is left over so that is where
it goes at the end okay now what I am
going to do I am going to do a console
DOT log of x
and then I'll go do
console.log of Y so that I can actually
print and see like what exactly it
prints now I have defined let's just do
collect things sorry let's just do
collect
things and then pass some arguments any
number five six seven eight nine okay
nine enough now what I'm going to do I'm
going to call collect things with nine
arguments I can pass hundred thousands
millions if I have time okay so let's
test it with nine so what will happen
the first argument that gets mapped to
the first parameter so x value will be
one
and the rest of it 2 to 9 goes to the
rest parameter so it means y will now
accept from 2 to 9 but within an array
okay so if I just printing it so if you
see the first Sprints X is 1 and then
rest of the eight goes inside an array
two to nine this this subscript is a
array notation two to nine and that that
get assigned this enter array get
assigned to this y parameter that's why
it's called rest parameter hope it was
again easy for you to understand and it
will try to practice a lot about the
rest parameter
[Music]
let's learn about Arrow function or fat
Arrow syntax
all right so we know how to define a
function right let's do it again but
this time
let's repeat the one we did with
function expression const add equals to
of function and then we have two
parameters over here and then we have
return of
X Plus Y and finally we close this
particular breast
so that works that's great right now
what we can do over here to convert this
one to a arrow function or fat Arrow
syntax there are few adjustments that
you have to do so initially the arrow
function or the factors index looks
little weird but how I try to kind of
remember writing it and right now what
happened is like I hardly write a
function in the regular definition or
Declaration way it's always about
writing the function with the fat Arrow
syntax or the arrow syntax okay so let's
convert it if you're new to it you will
take some time to get a grip on it but
once you get a grip on it I'm sure that
you are going to write the arrow
function again and again because now I'm
coming to the usage of it because the
best uses you will write less number of
code you will write lesser amount of
code and be it any framework or any
library today in the modern web
development I think the diff Factor the
very normal coding Syntax for function
is using error function it doesn't mean
that you cannot go with the traditional
way of declaring and defining function
or declare a different functions using
expressions like the one we see on the
screen you can always go with that but
if you use add a function or you use fat
Arrow syntax it's like you know much
more modern is much more less code and
of course there is one more thing that
is there which I won't be covering in
this crash course in the button the
following one the relationship with the
this keyword and arrow function Arrow
functions no binding to this
keyword that is what is another special
case that comes but that will be
covering into the this video that this
keyword video that I'll be making next
okay but let's now focus on how to
convert this one to Arrow function okay
so to convert this one what I have to do
simple link one is I'm going to remove
this function keyword so you don't need
function keyword at all to make an arrow
function next we are talking about this
Arrow function so you need an arrow so
arrow is a combination of this equal
screen and this getter done so if you
have a greater than and the equals and
the greater than key without any space
side by side you actually have an arrow
like syntax and this is what is making
is an arrow function so this is an arrow
function Okay const add this is the
parameter that we are taking and then
what is happening basically I am having
an arrow and then the definition of the
function that's all about the error
function so I'm not using the function
keyword at all so let's just make sure
that it runs 2 comma 3 it runs five
okay very good but one more thing that I
can do if the arrow function body the
error functions declaration having only
one statement just one line and one and
and it's returning something you don't
have to even give this you know curly
braces so this one you can very well
Define like you don't need this just get
rid of it
and then you get rid of it that's it so
this syntax compared to this one you
know the with the function keyword this
is much much simpler isn't it so if you
have a syntax like this it is it is way
way easy for you and if it is something
like you know you have dependency with
just one parameter over here you don't
have to give this parenthesis you can
actually do things like this so if you
have
you know just one line stuff over here
so it's much much simpler so this is the
reason why a error function is very well
you know appreciated sorry very well
appreciated by the developer Community
it is very well received by developer
Community because you will be writing
very less syntaxes very less code and in
all the modern uh web development uh you
know area data function is used very
heavily so please practice writing Arrow
function and I hope that you keep
writing more and more error functions in
your code than writing the function more
traditional way
thank you
[Music]
all right so nested function what does
nesting means we know how to create a
function let's say we create a function
called outer
and that function has a body
and it can have certain instruction like
what is this function supposed to do
maybe in this case the function is
supposed to print something called outer
into the log
now JavaScript allows you to create a
function to define a function within
within another function okay it might
sound little bit strange if you're new
to it but this is a very very powerful
feature and this is the first basic
thing
towards understanding the concept of
closure the concept of closure in
functions in JavaScript function equals
to the understanding of nested function
plus function scope so if you want to
understand closure deeply I want your
attention over here first understand
what nested function is how does it work
up next we'll be talking about function
scope and then we'll be talking about
closure so that everything is very very
clear to you and is very straightforward
to you all right so nested function so
function within a function this means I
can create another function over here
give it a name maybe for Simplicity I'm
giving it an inner and I can give a
console.log
as I've defined this function using the
outer function this function is called a
nested function and this nested function
as I have defined outside you know
inside this outer function I have to
call this one inside the outer function
itself
okay
so like this so right now if I have
defined it this way and if I call the
outer function what will happen the
outer function will be invoked it will
print this console.log then it will see
this inner function has been defined the
definition happened and after that it
will invoke the inner function also so
what will be the output if I do this
outer over here okay so the output is
outer and then the inner so it first
print the log outer and then the
definition happen the inner get executed
and this this inner actually gets print
out so you can have nesting to any level
in JavaScript functions however you
won't see in practice uh you know too
much level of nesting but you definitely
will see now if you go back and see the
code the various JavaScript code you
will definitely will see some level of
nesting some level of defining one
function another inside another function
happening and it's a very powerful
feature we'll be able to see this in a
moment okay
[Music]
just now we have seen what nested
function is
and now we are stepping into
understanding function scope okay these
two are a bit interrelated because you
have to understand the concept of nested
function you can define a function
within another function
and then the function scope is important
to understand who can access what okay
now there are certain generic rules but
to understand those rules I thought a
graphical picture will be much more
important so please pay attention to
this graphic over here so let's say
there is a Javascript file you know and
a function is defined inside that so the
function is running globally it means
that the function is not inside any
other function so this blue one is a
function this particular function is not
inside any other function okay if the
function is just defined globally now
what happened there are there are
actually two rules two primary rules
that you have to keep in mind and these
two rules are very important if you
understand I want to understand closure
okay so the first rule over here is
variable that are defined inside a
function the variable that are defined
inside a function that cannot be
accessed anywhere outside of the
function
okay so the variable that this one is
defined inside this function
cannot be accessed from anywhere outside
of the function okay so anything defined
in this blue box cannot be accessed
outside of the blue box understood first
principle okay a variable defined inside
a function cannot be accessed anywhere
outside of the function
second principle the opposite of it a
function
can access all the variables
inside the scope it is defined
a function
can access all the variable inside the
scope it is defined so it means this
blue function can access all the
variables that is defined you know in
the scope the function is defined in the
global scope so inside the global scope
if I am defining I am having any
variable I will be able to access that
from this function but the reverse is
not true from the outside you cannot
access the thing which is insight
understood this to rule let's repeat
this rule again because it's very
important for us to kind of understand
closure
variables defined inside a function
cannot be accessed anywhere outside of
the function first rule second a
function can access all the variables
inside the scope that it is defined so
this blue box is defined in the global
Scopes in the global scope if there are
any variables from this blue box the
from the blue function I should be able
to access it great now we have learned
about nested function no so just replace
This Global with a function and this
function one with the nested function
okay in our function so the global is
outer function and this function is an
inner function in this case also then
the formula remains same the rule
applicable over here also so it means
your outer function cannot access
anything from the inner function as the
inner function is defined in this outer
function so it means the inner function
will be able to access anything that is
defined in this outer function because
inner function is defined in the outer
function scope
very simple right so now if it goes keep
going nesting like in if there is
another function inside is there is
another function inside same rule
applicable we have the same rule applied
over there so this is how it works so
you have to keep this thing in your mind
now we are going to see with some code
example here okay we'll be seeing some
code example over here but you have to
really remember this rule that a
variable defined inside a function
cannot access anywhere outside of the
function you know from outside of the
function a function can access all the
variables inside the scope that it is
defined so these arrows and these things
if you give me keep it in your mind I
think things will be very clear okay so
let's move on and try to see like how
the things Works code wise we'll be
doing some coding now so based on the
rules that we have learned so far we are
going to write the code so that we
understand this thing clearly right
let's create a function let's create a
function call say do something
okay and what is this function doing
it's basically
um let's create a few variables inside
that okay so let's do let x equals to 10
const y equals to 20
and then let const okay let's get VAR
Z equals to 30 okay and then simply
we'll do a console.log of X comma y
comma Z okay so we know if I now to do
something
I just call this function I know what
will be the output is 10 20 30 very very
uh straightforward things that we have
created over here okay so but
this is where our rule number one comes
into the picture what was the rule
number one variable define inside of
function cannot be accessed from outside
right so it means I have defined let X
const Y VAR Z inside the do something
function and I've executed to something
it's executed this console.log XYZ now
if I try to take this console.log and
try to execute outside
what is going to happen
do you see that it says X is not defined
okay X is not defined maybe X is late so
is not able to define y also is
constantable how about the VAR
no even if it is VAR and it is defined
within a function you cannot access this
variable outside a scope outside of this
function you cannot access that is the
first principle that we have learned
just now right now second principle what
was the second principle do you remember
the second principle was about uh if the
function basically now can access
anything and everything from its scope
basically the scope where it is defined
to okay so let's see the second rule now
what we'll be doing we'll be defining
VAR x equals to 10
advanced y equals to 20
late
Z equals to
30 okay now if I do
uh function
do something
and
do a
console DOT log of x comma y comma Z
what do you think will happen
if I just execute do something
what will happen
do you think it is going to give an
error or is going to print
is going to print successfully why
because our second rule say wherever the
function whatever the scope the function
is defined in that scope if there are
variables declared the function can
access this variable this function is
declared in the global scope it means
that function is not inside another
function so it means if the global scope
is having any variables so the function
will be able to access those variables
inside the function itself but when we
did the thing other way around we have
declared all this thing inside the
function and tried to access them from
outside it doesn't work so these two
rules Define the functional scope the
scope that we are talking about is the
functional scope you have to remember
what is accessible where simple thing if
it is in the outer scope if it is if it
is defined in the same scope where the
function is defined it is accessible
within the function but if it is defined
within the function it is not accessible
from outside even if it is a VAR that is
declared and defined inside the function
clear about it great
foreign
[Music]
so ask a developer about a complex
JavaScript topic
there are higher chances that you'll
hear back closures
this is because
the closures are not understood
fundamentally by connecting the dots
okay from connecting the dots point of
view if you don't know about connecting
the dots and creating a mind map to
learn a complex topic I have created a
video on how to learn JavaScript by
connecting the dots please go ahead and
take a look now coming back to closures
if you learn closures by connecting the
dots you will find closures
understanding much easy if you just jump
into closure and trying to understand
you may not understand it well but if
you come from the background of nested
function then function scope you will be
able to understand closure very easily
okay so let's get into understanding
closures so that we can actually fill it
it's easy
take a look into this picture on your
screen
so there is a box inside that there is
another box consider this one as an
outer function and this one as an inner
function we have learned about the
nested function already right so let's
give them a name for example I'll give
them give the for this one as F1 as a
function one or will I'll give it as a
name say outer to be very sure that
they're out this is outer and this one
of course inner now I know if I Define a
variable over here say a
this variable is not accessible from
outside but if I Define a variable over
here say B this variable is accessible
from inside the inner function so we
have learned this in the nested function
and the function scope very clearly okay
now
what is closure
the nested function is a closure this
inner function is nothing but a closure
okay as simple as that
so if anybody asks you a definition of
closure you can tell this nested
function is a closure
now if you go for a bookish
you know closure definition for example
if you go to mdn and try to look for
what is closure you will get a
definition like a closure is a function
that can have three variables together
with an environment that can run that
variable okay which means
it the the environment means nothing but
this inner function and the variable
means every variable that is defined
inside that inner function and there is
an ability through which you will be
able to run things which is in this
inner function so this inner function is
basically is a closure okay is it's it
this is how we should be understanding
closure now let me summarize
the inner function can be accessed
only from the statements
in the outer function correct we'll see
it in code also and the inner function
from a closure it means the inner
function can use the variables the
arguments everything from the outer
function while the outer function cannot
use the arguments and the variable from
the inner function we have seen with
this one if we understand like what is
closure the closure is nothing but the
nested function because it provides an
environment you know to the outer world
so this nested function can leave
you know longer the nested function can
leave longer for execution and it can
actually perform the the all the
required operations right so let's write
a function
will give the name as outer
and let's take a parameter of this one
outer function
and then let's take another function
nested function which is like inner
we will also take a parameter over here
and what we can do here this is the
beauty of it the inner function can
access the outer functions variable and
argument so I can do return X Plus Y
correct inner function can access the
outer functions argument or any variable
that is declared inside outer function
so I can do return X Plus y pretty well
over here okay and then finally what I
can do I can do return
you know okay
I am returning this inner function as
well
okay now since the inner function the
inner function is which one this one
forms the closure this is what is
closure okay now what I can do basically
I can call this outer function
okay and specify the argument and then
leverage both outer and inner together
that's the advantage okay so let me see
how can I do this
I'll just press enter
now first what I can do const
outer return
equals to
outer let's give 10 what do you think
will be returned over here this is this
is this is the this is the most
interesting part what will return so
once we call this outer function outer
function return nothing but a function
which is like an inner function now when
the function execution is over the call
is over that function is over right that
function is no word in the picture so if
I in press an enter over here outer is
just over it is nowhere in the picture
but the beauty of it the beauty of it is
the argument I have passed to Outer it
still leaves where it still leaves
inside inner because this stain was
passed over here this stain is still
used over here and it still leaves even
after the outer execution because outer
Returns the inner so inner is actually
over here outer return so let me just if
I just do outer return for you if I just
do this one and print this for you what
it returns is returns inner y return X
Plus y so is written this function where
X is nothing but this 10 that I have
passed so though the execution of outer
is over but the value that we have
passed throughouter still leaves within
inner so it means it means if I just
execute Outer Outer return now o u t
here outer return now
with the parameter set 2
is going to give me the output of 12 why
because outer return is nothing but this
inner function inner function expects a
parameter over here the parameter that I
have passed as you know pass the
argument over here but what it did it
actually use this 2 with a variable that
I have passed long back and the
execution is over that's why this is
called closure this is created a closure
closure is nothing but the variables and
an environment that you can actually
execute freely what do you mean by
freely it means usually in functions
whenever the function execution is
completely over this is done any
variable that is that is actually
created inside that that's all gone is
basically you are not going to get it
anymore but in this case though outer is
executed long back but the argument or
the parameter we have passed through
outer is still leaves within inner
because inner is a closure and I can
actually utilize it you know at a later
point of time so this is what the
concept of closure that you need to
understand this is what you need to
understand is like uh why closure is
really a handy method why closure is
really useful so you can
a used closure for various use cases one
of the use case that I have seen over
here is like preserving the variable so
I have passed 10 though the function
execution is over but still 10 is
preserved over here and as it is
preserved over here it can be utilized
with another value to compute something
and return right that's why the closure
is useful in the video that I'll be
creating focusing on closure only there
I'll be talking about much more real
life examples and the use case that you
can actually build with closure so as
you understand closure fundamentally
right now start practicing start
creating this kind of a small example
where your outer function inner function
outer inner both take some argument you
return the inner function from the outer
function and see after outward execution
gets over how the value that you have
passed throughout or you can still use
inside in or at a later point of time so
this kind of thing the example that you
are seeing over here try to find out
this example over internet or try to
cook something yourself and try to
practice it more use case oriented
example like real life use case oriented
example of closure that will come in a
dedicated period I hope this clarify
your concept now just to recap it once
the closure
understanding is depending on your
understanding of nested function plus
function scope We Know by nested
function that a function can Define one
more function within it we know why the
function scope is like the outer
function cannot access any variable
inside the inner function however inner
function can access any variable and the
argument of the outer function this
ability gives us a very powerful feature
called closure through which even if the
outer function execution is over but we
can persist circuited values which was
passed to the outer function within
inner function and compute it at a later
point of time that becomes a powerful
feature itself a powerful design pattern
itself in JavaScript which is called
closure I hope this is clear to you
[Music]
now we learn about callback functions
what is callback okay so everything is
in the name itself call back it means
call it back some point of time but
let's understand with some exam
now in JavaScript
function is a first class citizen what
do you what do you mean by that it means
that we can create a function we have
seen function definition we can assign a
function we have seen like when we do
const x equals to function and then
basically we can assign this function to
a variable we can assign a function
we can return we can define a function
with another function we have seen this
from the nested function
now the next thing that we are going to
see is like we can pass function
as a parameter to another function okay
that is where the Callback function
comes into picture and we'll see what's
his use cases are okay first let's
define a function called Foo okay and
this is the full function
what is this Foo function doing over
here
let's assume that full function cat can
take another function as a parameter
let's pass another function function as
a parameter called boo
or let's call Bar because that's who bar
bus are the things that we usually use
these names for example
now
as this function
ticks and
you know argument
which is nothing but another function so
it means I can capture it as a bar
parameter and assume that this bar is
nothing but another function so it means
that inside this I should be able to
execute this function very simple
if it was a string I could have printed
the string or concaten it with something
else or done something with the screen
if it is a number I would have done
something with the number if it is a
function I'll simply execute this
function now to execute this function we
know that we have to give this
parenthesis to call this function or
execute this function
this particular function is called a
callback
okay this particular function is called
a callback pump but why
will come to that but first I want to
execute this how do we execute this one
I have defined it now if I have to
execute this I know that 4 takes a
function so I can actually pass a
function to it
okay and let's do something like
this
so what I did
who takes a function of course we told
put x a function the bar is a function
and we execute it inside that this means
that
I can pass a function as an argument to
Foo so I have passed a function do you
guys realize one thing over here I have
created a function which doesn't have a
name so this function is called
Anonymous function the function that
doesn't have a name is called Anonymous
function because it doesn't have a name
and as I will be using this function
instantly over here I didn't bother
about creating it again okay so if I
just execute this one this function get
passed over here and then it gets
executed in this line once it get
executed in this line this console.log
gets executed and it prints bar
same thing what I can do instead of
doing this line for you to understand is
better I can create a function with a
name for example function named
and instead of that I can actually say
console.log of bar again same thing like
the previous function instead of passing
it directly
now I can do
of named
right is exactly the same thing that
whatever instead of again declaring the
function with the name function and then
passing the function over here I just
pass the function directly over there
that's the only difference but output is
same
okay so now you know a function can take
a function as an argument and I can
actually do that and the function which
is passed as a parameter and I am using
it you know
um inside it at a later point of time is
called callback function but why it's
called callback function that's the
thing let's go from the beginning again
to understand Y is called a callback
function so again we'll be defining
function Foo take another function bar
and let's say I have some condition
condition is if
it's night
consider is Knight is a Boolean variable
it can be true or false in that case you
call Bar okay usually under at the night
only like you know bars will be like
flourishing everywhere or let's say
another condition is there if
is
drinks
over
check
online
in this case only okay spelling mistake
check online in this case itself you
call bar so we have two conditions
where we want to call this particular
function call Bar the one condition is
if it is night then call Bar function or
maybe do an online call or network call
to check whether the drinks is over then
I'll you call bar so it means that
calling back bar is based on certain
kind of conditions that is happening
within this function this is a case
where you actually want to call this
function as a call back function you are
calling it back based on certain
conditions based on certain things it is
so so amazingly powerful because you can
pass any function to another function
and call this past function based on any
condition at a later point of time
that's why it is called callback now if
you want to understand this concept with
much deeper example I have created an
example with the pizza Hub or the pizza
Hub and the little boy story is like a
storytelling so that anybody can
understand then that video is already
out there go ahead and check out that
video the link of the video is in the
description of this video you can check
out and find out like you know how in a
real life application you can use
callback uh you know effortlessly so I
hope the Callback functions is clear to
you now
foreign
[Music]
about higher order function higher order
function or Hof okay what is higher
order function
a higher order function by definition is
a regular function it's a normal
function that takes one or more function
as an argument
and or returns of function as a value
from it okay let's write it down speed
complex in that way
so one condition is like it takes
one or more
functions as argument
okay this is the first thing and then
the second thing
it may return
of function okay so not necessarily both
the conditions has to be made for a
higher order function if any of the
condition
emits it's actually a higher order
function now we just now spoke about a
callback function right what is told
about callback function a callback
function is a function which takes a
function as an argument based on certain
conditions or something whatever the
function we are passing as an argument
it is going to invoke that function
inside now in the first case of the H of
Hof higher order function is about
taking one or more function as an
argument so it means there is a
relationship between a higher order
function and a callback function and
that is where sometime in interviews
interviewers put some tricky question is
Hof and callback are same no Hof and
callback are not exactly same because
for callback functions it is not
mandatory for the main function to
return any function it can accept the
function as a argument do something with
it but it is not necessary that it has
to return a function in whereas in
higher order function if the function
return another function
it calls a higher order function in that
case also it calls higher order function
okay so it means that
if I am just taking like a function okay
let's take a function uh let's give it
the name call gate capture and let's
take a parameter called camera okay
now if I am doing like this
this is a higher order function why
because camera is a function and I am
executing this one over here so I can
actually call
get capture
over here
I can call
sorry about that I can call get capture
over here
and pass a function to it I can say
function
okay do a console
console.log
say
Canon
okay so hit execute this is what we have
seen when we understood a callback
functions methodology now we can do the
other other part also like a function
returning another function which is also
called a higher order function so how it
will be we can actually do like function
return the FN
and it can
return
of function
with say
the console.log of
returning something we are printing over
here to
prove that it works now how am I going
to execute this multiple ways to execute
it for example
const
say FN
equals to I can do return FN
to return FN
when I return FN what it does it return
a function right now so if I do this so
FN is now nothing but a function if you
see that the moment I am typing FN it is
giving F if I just do a printout over
here it is running a function to execute
this one it means I need the parenthesis
okay so it will execute this one so this
is one way that I actually can execute
this thing so I hope this is
quite clear now do you if you are
working on JavaScript for some time you
are already using some of the higher
order function you know already and this
higher order function is extremely
extremely useful for you know your core
reliability predictability
um aspects of it you are already using
some of these things called array
functions like map filter reduce
uh find all this method that you have
right on the arrays are all higher order
functions because they are also you
write a code like you know one if I
takes like one comma two comma 3 and on
this side you do something like filter
and in here you pass a function right
your filter condition you pass over here
if you are using array already you will
know that and this is where you actually
put your condition like based on which
condition you want to filter this one
out right you can get this like element
and if the element greater than 2 uh
greater than three you know you actually
write conditions like that and based on
that you filter the things out so
uh this is an example of a higher order
function like how why exactly it's
called higher order function and where
you use the error
now again if you want to get a very very
deep look of higher order function as it
is crash course we are not getting into
too much deep but you want to get a very
good deep a higher order function I have
already created a video for it please
take a look at it I am sure that you
will enjoy learning higher order
function and try to understand what are
the different use cases apart from
built-in JavaScript functions whenever
you are coding in what cases you will be
using higher order functions please take
a look
[Music]
let's see what a pure function is in
JavaScript when I click with function
you deal with a lot of pure functions
you also deal with lot of impure
function by definition a pure function
is a function that produces the same
output for the same input
same output for the same input okay so
function
say
greeting input is name
and what is going to do is going to
return a greeting message okay so return
hello
and
yeah so this kind of greeting message is
going to be done so fair enough so if I
call say greeting
and pass my name
is going to return hello so
for same input is going to return same
output if I as many times I am going to
input Tapas that many times it is going
to return hello Tapas if I do hello
YouTube it is going to return hello
YouTube as many times I am going to
input YouTube that many times is going
to Output hello YouTube pure function
this is pure function pure functions
helps in predictability it means that if
the input is same output will be always
same so this is very very predictable
what is impure function just the
opposite of that it means that for the
same input it's not going to create the
same output okay so same function if I
just do a little bit different way so
for example let me create a variable
called greeting and
what I did now initialized with hello
okay now I I have a function like
function you know this guy I'll just
copy this so that I can utilize it
but I'll change a little bit what I'll
be changing instead of this hello hard
coding hello now I am taking this
greeting from here okay
all right so if I now say a greeting
Tapas it will give hello fair enough
if I give Tapas again it will give hello
fair enough but if I change this
greeting variable
value 2 from Hello to hola hello to hola
and then
I do it again for the same input Tapas
the output becomes so from hello hello
Tapas it becomes it means say greeting
is not producing the same output for the
same input right now because it is
depending on something either something
is called side effect what is the side
effect the side effect is nothing but a
variable which is outside of the scope
of say greeting function and say
greeting cannot control this particular
variable any anyone can change which can
create a side effect such that this
particular function is no more appear
function it is no more returning the
same output for the same input so this
is the difference between a pure versus
impure function can you write all the
functions as pure function in your
application may not be you may not be
able to write you know all the functions
as a pure functions because there will
be side effects you need things like
that you have to make Network call you
have to probably write something on the
console log everything is side effect
but as much as possible if you can make
certain things as pure you have more
more predictability for those cases so
look out for this thing
again if you want to get deeper to Pure
function you want to learn like the real
life use case of previewer function
where exactly we use where can we make
use of it I have created an extensive
video for Pure function take a look at
it so that you can learn and practice it
much more alright so I hope now you got
the basic fundamental understanding of a
pure and impure function
[Music]
alright friends so let's learn iif what
is iif is an abbreviation of the term
immediately invoked function Expressions
I for immediately then I for invoked
then if for function e for expression
immediately invoked function expression
what does it mean it means is a function
expression that's where the code inside
the function gets executed immediately
after it's been defined now let's take a
function for example
function
X this is the function right which is
having a name X now if I have to execute
this function at a later point of time
whenever I want in my code what I'll do
I'll just use this name with the
parenthesis and I'll execute this
function okay that's great now the only
reason why this name exists the X for
this function is because I can use this
name to execute this function at a later
point of time maybe wherever I have
defined this function after 200 lines
after that based on certain logic I am
I'm executing I'm calling I'm invoking
this function all right but iif says
the use of iif is to execute the
function immediately after it's been
defined so if I have to do that I don't
need the name of the function because
the moment I Define right after defining
the function I want to execute it so I
don't need a name so let's start with
something which doesn't have a name so I
did function X before I don't give any X
now rather I have created something like
this
but if I try to run this it's going to
give me a problem saying that function
statement required a function name okay
so now I cannot create an anonymous
function like this and let's just keep
it as it is because it's required
function name okay now let me introduce
a operator called group operator which
is nothing but a bunch of
parenthesis now if I put this Anonymous
function the function without a name
inside this group you know operator
what happened if I just driven enter it
actually gives me the string
representation of this particular
function itself the string
representation of this function itself
correct without any name bursting
representation in previous chapters we
have seen whenever we get a string
representation of this function itself
it means it's a function so it means I
can actually give the parenthesis after
that to execute it so it means if I take
this guy and just put a parenthesis
around this it means it will be executed
yeah so I have got a proper function
that's got executed so this is what is
iif so now let me write a few code
inside the so that you know that it's
getting executed so console.log iif if I
just try to execute this you see that
iaf was printed so the function when I
am defining at the same time I am also
executing this function
that is what is iif that is what is
immediately invoke function expressions
now if you ask why does it exist
there are a few reason why it exists
before es6 I mean before we had like
late const all this better way of
managing accessibility of a variable
like where it where what can be accessed
where where things cannot get polluted
where you have
um you know before es6 where you had
only VAR like the chance of your Global
variable gets polluted you had no other
option that using iif to protect them
okay also another reason is like a very
normal reason is like when you create a
function with a function name it means
the function name unless it is a like
nested function or inner function the
function name basically exists in the
global context right in the globally it
is not inside any other function so it
means there are chances that somebody
else might be using the similar function
name somewhere else might there is a
chance of kind of or a variable name
with the same name as the function name
and the channel of getting it polluted
so for that not to happen the iif can be
used so Ife can be used for various
different use cases but the concept of
iip is this that whenever you actually
Define the function immediately after
that you want to execute it only in this
case you use the syntax and use that IAP
I hope the syntax breakdown also makes
sense to you because it doesn't need a
name so we started with an anonymous
function then we actually used a group
operator around that so that we get a
function definition and then the last
parenthesis basically a pair of
parenthesis used always to call or
invoke the function we use it along with
it and we got an iif result then and
there I hope it was useful thanks for
watching
[Music]
so you are going to understand call
stack but before understanding call
stack we have to understand function
executions very well okay so first we'll
understand what call stack is and also
we'll understand what is function
execution so that you get a complete
clear picture about it the element that
gets inside the stack first it comes out
last right so here consider there are
three elements like F1 F2 F3 they went
in like first F1 then F2 then F3 but
when it had to come out the F3 come out
first then F2 and then F1
that's how the stock stack works now
instead of a normal variable if a
function gets inside a stack
then it will be like similar way like
first F1 F2 F3 gets in and then F3 F2 F1
it comes out in this sequence so when a
function gets executed there is a stack
that JavaScript engine maintains okay
and in that stack it defines like how
the execution of this particular
function takes place whenever JavaScript
interpreter go line by line in an
encounter a function call or a function
invocation it puts that function inside
a stack execute it and once the
execution is over it takes it out from
the stack the reason for doing this
there is a proper sequence of how the
functions are getting executed can be
maintained through the stack data
structure we are going to see that with
example all right so the first example
that we are going to take there are
three functions F1 F2 F3 you are able to
see in on the screen each of this
function have bunch of code that can be
executed whenever we are invoking or
calling this function so we are calling
this functions first F1 first then F2
then F3 right side we have a function
execution stack or call stack so call
stack and execution stack are the same
and what we're going to see like when
these functions are getting executed
like first F1 gets call what happened to
call stack for then F2 what happened to
call stack then F3 what happens to call
stack that's what we want to learn okay
so please pay an attention to this call
stack and also the how the code is
getting executed so first thing first F1
F1 gets executed F1 gets inside the call
stack or the function execution stack
inside F1 bunch of code okay all done
done getting executed there is no
function inside it so nothing else to
put at this point of time inside this
tag then F1 execution is over take out
F1 from it next F2 gets executed put F2
similarly over there there is no
function inside it but execute all the
code execute F2 take it out then goes to
F3
again put F3 inside the stack execution
is done there is no function bunch of
code getting get it executed it's out so
it's very simple F1 F2 F3 is got
executed now let's take a little bit
complex scenario with this code
so what is happening here you have F1
your bunch of code there is no function
in it then you have F2 you have bunch of
code but there is a function F1 which
you have defined before we are invoking
over here you remember a function can
have another function inside it a
function can invoke another function
inside it yes so this is an example so
F2 basically invoke F1 or call F1 inside
it along with a bunch of code F3 there
is no other code other than it is
executing F2 this is like a chain right
so any invoke F3 it is actually invoking
F2 F2 executing a bunch of code and
invoking F1 F1 executing a bunch of code
but no function invocation inside F1 now
how this can be depicted into call stack
or the function execution stack that's
what you're going to see so again pay
attention on the right side first what
happened when F3 executes when F3
executes it finds F2 but before that F3
has to go inside the call stack because
of function has to go inside call stack
to get executed so now F3 get executed
it finds F2 oh yeah so if to another
function so before I take out F3 out of
it because F3 will be taken out only
when F3 is complete execution is over
but is not over now the cursor is at f2
so it has to put F2 inside F to Cave
inside so f2's execution gets started
but F3 is still in the call stack so F2
is execution a bunch of code is executed
this line get executed this line get
executed oh now it encountered F1 which
is also a function so it's time to put
it in the call stack the F1 got the call
stack now if you see in the call stack
or the function execution stack you have
F1 F2 F3 but in the reverse order of how
they have got into right now we are the
af1 F1 a punch of line of quora there
let's execute them one by one but there
is no function so nothing else to put
into the call stack but execution when
it is over for F1 we have to take it out
from the call stack F1 is over now our
cursor is over here so if one's
execution is over that means f2's
execution is also now over take out F2
so cursor is over here f2's execution is
over the next line there is no more code
that means F3 time to take it out isn't
that awesome so this is exactly what
function execution stack or call stack
that's how it works that's how
JavaScript and engine maintains at what
sequence your function should be
executed I hope it is very clear to you
right now now this particular concept is
very very important if you want to learn
JavaScript asynchronous programming
deeply I have a complete series created
for JavaScript asynchronous programming
if you are interested go ahead and take
that series I'm sure that you will be
able to master that concept very very
quickly alright thank you for watching
[Music]
Hello friends let's talk about recursion
what is recursion recursion means a
function that refer or call itself okay
what does it mean let's create a
function let's say function Foo and
inside that we create we do we Okay
function 4 inside that we do a
console.log let's say who and then we
say that a recursion is something where
the function can refer or call itself so
in this case we'll call itself what
happens when we invoke this so we invoke
who okay are you with me what is going
to happen
do you see what happened the function is
keep calling keep calling keep calling
keep calling and after some point of
time
is going to say maximum call stack size
exceeds so if you know about function
call stack now it means that who is
going to put itself
multiple times into the call stack call
stack also multiple times and once will
happen the call stack has a max size
Define when the max size limit the
threshold limit reached is going to give
the error called maximum call strike X
call stack exceeds so that's the error
that we are getting
okay but if you're getting an error what
is the use of a recursion okay we'll
come to that just a second but before
that this is one way that we can
actually
define recursion like a function is
actually in Booking itself let's do
another way that's why how the recursion
can be done so for example const
equals to
function
bus
and then inside this
what I'm going to do
I can call Foo
like this what will happen so in this
case I have created a function
and the function is assigned to a
variable called Foo so that means who
itself is a function so in this case Foo
and Buzz are almost same the way that
you call Foo here or you call Buzz here
whatever it is you are actually creating
a recursion here because now you are
referring to for this particular
function either with who or with bus
whatever name it is it's the same
function so that's the another way you
create the recursion so in this case
also it will just uh okay who is already
exist because I have used this name
before uh so if you actually use it it
is going to actually create the
recursion for you okay both the cases
are same now we saw like with recursion
what was happening it was just creating
uh it was calling itself calling itself
calling itself and then it hits the
maximum hip size and and the it is error
out then why should we use recursion
okay so one thing is like whenever you
are using red recursion
you have to make sure that you have
something called base condition okay
this is very important so recursion
without a base condition is not of much
use base condition means under which
condition you have to stop the recursion
so you have to stop the recursion at
some point of time because you want to
stop the execution of that function to
execute itself at some point of time
so that you can exit it out or do
something else so that condition is
called best condition okay so usually
how you will be writing things in
recursion in a recursion program so you
will try writing something like function
recurs
function recurs
if it is a best condition if
base
condition
in that case
you probably do something and after that
you return
otherwise continue to records
so this is how you actually do recursion
you should have a best condition and if
there is a base condition you do
something and then return from it
otherwise you continue to recurse okay
let's write a program so that we can
actually understand this in in much
better way okay so the program that will
be writing is about let's say only
fetching water multiple times so let's
call a function try to create a function
called pitch
water
and
let's take a parameter called count like
how many times you want to fetch the
water and we say if
the count is
this is our best condition okay we have
written the best condition in that case
you do something maybe I'll do like
console.log and say like
no more water left so sad
okay done and then I will return
otherwise keep fetching the water
and I will do like count
minus 1 and we can do a console.log here
also saying
unsold.log so etching water okay we'll
see the enter code and then after
fetching water
we'll do that line got deleted somehow
paste water down to minus one all right
so let's read this code once more what
we are doing we have a fetch water
we are calling fetch water again here is
a recursion of course but we have a best
condition also the best condition is
Wayne will be exiting from this
recursion our base condition says your
in the count is zero then I am saying no
more water left and break this recursion
but rental count is zero I am just
recursing it just fetching the water
correct so now if I say
fetch water
five times what will happen
it will go count is 5 is equals to zero
no it won't go inside that base
condition doesn't mate which the water
become count four so count four means
again call the same function with count
four so count four comes here is 4 is
equals to zero no again base condition
doesn't mean it can fetch the water now
call the same fetch water with four
minus one that is three keep doing this
until count is zero once the count is
zero
no more water left and you exit from the
recursion right we'll do
so fetching water fetching water
fetching water fetching water fetching
water and then no water left so we have
written a program using recursion and
you also have the best condition through
which we exit this recursion right now
the same thing you could have done with
for Loop isn't it the same function same
functionality would you could have done
it with follow so there is always some
debate like whether you should be using
recursion versus using for Loop
wherever the follow applicable maybe we
should be using for Loop but in some
cases for example you want to create the
factorial of a number factorial means
factorial of n or factorial of 5 means 5
into 4 into 2 3 into 2 into 1 right so
the if you want to do a factorial maybe
the recursion is the right way to go
because it makes the code much more
readable than doing a factorial using
for Loop right so readability is one of
the factor that you want to probably
take it into account when you use
recursion over for Loop wherever
recursion is applicable so that's all
about recursion you whenever somebody is
asking about you about recursion please
also mention that you have a best
condition where you can exit out from
recursion I hope it was useful it's all
right friends everything has to come to
an end so our this crash course also has
to come to an end I hope you enjoyed
learning all about the functions all the
things about functions some of them at a
very high level some of them in depth
but the purpose of this course was to do
a crash course where we can run through
all the aspects of JavaScript functions
and give you an idea give you the
confidence that you can learn some of
these Concepts if you learn
incrementally if you learn by connecting
the dots so we started with very basic
things like how to create a function and
end it with recursion in between we
touch nested function function scope
closure pure function callback all these
various aspects but your learning should
not stop here you need to keep
practicing each of this concept much
deep buy with your hands on and I have
videos for some of this concept to teach
much more deeper way for example
callback pure function Hof you know a
lot of these things are having in-depth
real life use case scenario videos
please go and watch them if you are
interested or if you want to read it
from somewhere or from some other
YouTube Channel please feel free to do
that but the learning should not stop
you this crash course purpose was to
give you a start give you the required
confidence so that you can now keep
learning alright all the best and again
a simple and small request please
subscribe to the channel if you have not
done already and hit the Bell button so
that whenever I publish a new video you
get a notification alright take care of
yourself I will come back
another video it is thank you